chris is with us in Arkansas hi Chris
how are you good sir how you doing
better than I deserve how can I help
well I was calling we uh I just
currently heard about you about three
months ago and I started listening to
you we actually started in the Financial
Peace University my wife and I last week
oh cool online and so we put everything
in we've got our thousand dollars we got
baby step one cleared out good IRS quick
we've got you know we started our we've
started our baby step two
we've got $1,100 $11,000 in back taxes
that we owe that the IRS audited us from
2017 and didn't accept on the right
office and so they they come back on us
we're in a chapter 13 bankruptcy from
2017 and we've got a RV that we bought a
couple months ago and we're trying to
figure out which way to pay I know the
IRS needs to pay off first but I'm
trying to figure out how to pay off the
other two as far as going the IRS the
chapter 13 and the RV yes sir
okay and so what are you owe on the RV
the RV is fifty nine thousand I work in
the oil field we lived in that RV it's
our house basically is what it is what
were you living in before you bought it
we had a old RV that we had bought two
years ago and the floor fell through on
us not a month ago this completely felt
fell out of it so we ended up upgrading
the RV is what we done yeah you did
fifty nine thousand dollar upgrade okay
yes sir I did put it into your system
it's showing that we can still pay
everything off in two years I'm just
trying to what is your what is your
household income a little over a hundred
thousand okay and what do you owe on the
chapter thirteen bankruptcy
total fifty
3:53 was the last I checked
but that included they included the
27,000 dollars worth of student loans
also yeah that was included in that
bankruptcy yeah and they pay a hundred
percent and you're paying a smaller
percentage on some of the other items
correct yes yeah five year plan from
2017 to 2023 are 20 22 yeah okay correct
all right well I always if reasonable if
it's not completely out of school I pay
the IRS first because they have very
high fees very high interest and
unlimited power to screw up your life
right so I want to pay them as soon as
possible so how much hundred thousand
dollar income how much debt are you
going to reduce a month quite a bit
quite a bit I'm looking at about five
thousand dollars going out okay I'm on
ten bills that I'm gonna be paying off
all right so that's like two months and
some change the IRS has gone yeah
they'll be gone in February the end of
February that's not two months that's
the for February weekend of February all
of January all of February all of
December and where I'm sitting home I
guess there's not that much left I'm
lost
okay so there's three months I'm sorry
instead of two yeah okay that's not
$5,000 a month so all right you got to
get your math straight but rs is first
yeah the RV is second bankruptcies last
okay and don't prepay the bankruptcy
without arranging it with the chapter 13
bankruptcy trustee you probably don't
need your login or most of the chapter
13 trustees or I've worked with them for
years most of them have run a very good
office a very tight ship and they are
very consumer oriented and they if
you'll call their office and ask for
some help on how you can pay this early
they'll help you set that up and you
won't even have to go through your old
attorney okay okay but that's the order
I would attack it and
so you've got a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars worth of debt making a
hundred so you're gonna be you're gonna
be shoveling for a while but you'll get
there you'll get there and you've got a
plan now and you're you're dialed in I
can hear it in your voice the way you're
talking about this so I mean if you
start talking about $60,000 a year
you'll be done in about two and a half
years if you stay on that track and
that's what you said was $5,000 a month
that's $60,000 a year doesn't get you to
February gets you a little over January
but anyway own RS but you do want those
people out of your life and you do to
get on a tight budget beans and rice
rice and beans so and don't buy anything
else on debt that's over